right in detail you've been through a
lot in your life you were bullied as a
kid you lost a father you you dated
women you were talking about that then
you met the love of your life but you
said many times in your life you had to
struggle between your private personal
life in your public Football Life what
do you mean by that
I would say my football life and my
football Persona comes with certain
expectations you know as a player Oh to
be you know masculine to be tough to
date women
um you know to be kind of this apex
predator of men and I say my private
life when I really mean private you know
we would keep things to yourself don't
everybody need to know everything about
what you do but when that privacy is
more of a secret secrets are shrouded
more than shame and when you start to
attribute that to to parts of yourself
like the people that you love your
relationships people things that should
bring Pride
um shame just makes it a very dark place
a lonely Place were you ashamed
I think definitely had a part